pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que didier ne pas oublier les
amendes salées mis les olives parfait
avant on allait ouvrir on me ferait
plaisir le maître un tablier propre
celui en normandie avec les volants dit
aux salles déjà alors l'autre henry
anglaise qui vous donnerait un coup de
peigne à ce sera pas du luxe
c'est mon un défrisage ya eu accord
circuit je sais pas comment vous faites
là pour filles mais on dirait que vous
attirez les catastrophes mais la foire
aux pommes j'irais bien d'un qu'est ce
que cette limite dont puisque c'est que
cette tâche-là et radis ce même souillac
bourbon va vous frotterez le tapis au
vinaigre et ce placard là qu'est ce que
vous attendez
bon le vide et il passait l'aspirateur
saint denis à poussière avec mes deux
bras
oui enfin je suis l'appartement est trop
grand duval est cuisinière femme de
chambre alors toutes été tenues
je vous assure moi je les ai plus on a
tous des hauts et des bas c'est la vie
bref je crois que j'ai décidé a affirmé
mme et deux salles on retient que je
crois que le bout le boudoir suffira et
je reverrai tout mon cocktail pas tant
pis il n ya pas la guerre on lui rebat
prenais ma fille que c'est pas une
guerre qui m'empêchera de recevoir pour
balle est maintenant retourner dans
votre cuisine
attendez un petit bruit de garde j'ai
pas touché mon chèque 26 retard ça vous
gêne pas que je vous règle votre moi
vers la fin de la semaine prochaine un
bon parfum si vous avez envie de sortir
ce soir je vous donne votre liberté
matin ça m'arrangerait mieux jeanne
enterrement
encore mais dites donc vous passez votre
vie aux enterrements sa mamie nova
jardin c'est toujours de l'équipement je
trouve que vous choisissez des
distractions un peu morbide dénature
trice bah faut réagir que du rabelais ou
pas que si l'ubs à fait comme les autres
quoi n'est pas d'amoureux après ce qui
m'est arrivé
quoi encore j'ai été violée moi madame à
l'âge de 15 ans allons-y
ils étaient six qui s'acharnait sur moi
dans la boue donc vous vous vantez ben
non madame il faisait nuit
ouais il n'avait pas porté plainte nous
avons offert une histoire vraie rose est
curieux tout de même enfin quoiqu'il en
soit vous n'êtes pas morte
j'aurais bien voulu voir ma date à plat
selon moi vous savez j'ai toujours pris
les choses par le bon côté à wasquehal
et l'ouvrir
bonsoir petite madame bonsoir comment et
où ce soir
viana et cats ont fait debout depuis
hier j'avais rendez vous avec huguette
pour les chercher des perches élan
filius je me suis dit comment des
j'avais pas le cours à vos trois rangs
non celui de culture marchés l'autre
jour au petit endroit j'étais sur le
point de sortir
vous les avez tout à récupérer ou moins
mais oui mon cher rassurez vous c'est
que la perle de culture aujourd'hui ça
va chercher très loin la richesse et
chasser un collier comme le vote il
fallait l'acheter aujourd'hui pour
raconter ou moins mmi à la tête par théo
a volontiers c'est celui que je vous ai
fait envoyer de lisbonne
ah oui toujours à merci excellent ma foi
mais hélas c'est la dernière bouteille
déjà non donnez moi encore une petite
goutte que j'en profite à l'or a monté
ce matin je me suis raide mais pour vous
il a monté il a monté il est en contrat
aidé en dessous de ce qu'il devrait être
enfin il a menti oui enfin beaucoup
moins qu'ils devaient baisser
d'ailleurs notre à il remontera ses
admirables évidemment qui remontera avec
ce papier qui ne vaut rien alors bon
alors je suis toujours immobilisés ont
signalé que c'est la fin du mois
heureusement la fin du mois enfin nous
sommes aujourd'hui le le 28 exactement
dans le mois d'octobre en compte 31
jours et enfin si vous voulez enfin
n'oubliez pas vous voyez bien que je ne
vous oublie pas puisque je suis là c'est
un grand ami et beau physique me sont la
terre et confort
je suis moi je n'ai que soucis et tracas
nani pensais plus
hoyau cette maison la tête pour voir une
douce retraite j'y suis très bien à la
bonne heure on a grand enfant voit tous
les hommes sont les grands enfants vous
moi mais là vous me comprenez hawaï mais
suis-je pas votre fidèle ami la dîtes
vous bien mon cher et vous n'êtes pas le
seul à avoir 10 ans maire de meaux enfin
bella mais qu'est ce qui vous prend il
m'apprend que j'en ai assez de me débats
au milieu de mille difficultés que vous
feignez dior et bonbons ne vous fâchez
pas ne vous fâchez pas je vais vous
signez une petite avance à petite avance
sur vos retards ah bon ben je suis le
pain and on a cette fois vous n'allez
pas vous en tirer aussi facilement
il va bien falloir que vous mais coutier
certainement vous avez mon oreille la
plus complaisant c'est pas votre règle
je veux l'oreille l'oreille et le reste
je vous en prie c'est par une humeur
d'écouter vos gauloiserie bon c'est fort
mais appelle la quille at-il il y a bah
il y a que je suis une femme les eaux
laissez moi rire dans un appartement
splendide rue spontini avec le trac
voulait l'appartement ils tombent en
ruine ben je trouve très doux pendant
mon retrait comme vous dites il consiste
en une seule sordide bonne à tout faire
que je n'ose même pas renvoyé parce que
je dois de l'argent me paraît très bien
cette fois été habitués au style à moi
je pense un bon petit hôtel de neuilly à
ma bentley abba parure de diamants roses
à où sont visibles idée mais sheila et
le manteau d'hermine dit et que je vous
ai fait il est pourri
je mettrai des volants disant
transformer en trois quarts puis en
boléro maintenant c'est un manchon
elle est prochaine il en sera tout juste
à ses poils pour faire un beau pont sur
un chapeau il fallait prévoir bella vous
étiez zuniga est passé l'argent ne
brûlait les doigts
oh mon dieu les banques ont fabuleux au
casino de monte car mais les temps ont
changé que diable nous sommes en 1950 2
et puis enfin mais là vous avez d'autres
satisfactions dans la vie je dirais plus
d'autres joies lesquels de chair amitié
par exemple ouais et puis une vie de
famille en bas parlons-en
enfin vous avez auprès de vous une fille
ravissante et qui vous adore est passé
là justement où je voulais en venir chez
un grand ami
delphine me pense bien que ceci quoi
elle a toujours les mêmes idées au
timbre va plus que jamais elle n'est pas
du tout du tout c'est rien trop lol
c'est la nouvelle génération pour garder
mon rang et joindre les deux bouts
je m'astreins à certaines corvée dont je
me dispense très volontiers je vous prie
de croire
j'espère que c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est bon on va vous croyez qu'elle
n'aurait keller stabilité et pourtant
vous avez tout fait pour lui mettre le
pied à l'étrier
vous êtes témoins outre la beauté qui
lui vient loi et puis les belles
manières
enfin je me suis toujours sacrifié pour
la mettre en avant vous vous rappelez le
chocolat kaen valter en est est ok quant
aux machines agricoles flix mon cher
elle ne se tenait plus le père ou le
fils les deux et je vous parle pas du
prince héritier de malaga qui était un
peu foncer je vous dis pas le contraire
mais après tout la nuit tous les chats
sont gris
allez-vous suis dû présenter la chose
cela mais ça ne présente pas ça se prend
les yeux fermés non mais vous vous
rendez compte un seul geste
les 3000 tonnes de coprah dans son lit
par an par mois non mais je vais faire
enseigner sans parler du caoutchouc qui
commence à donner
oui mais la guerre est un petit pays
plein d'avenir et m'a plu pour nous non
ça je vous le dis y'a rien à tirer de
cette petite a1 il faut vous faire une
raison
elle est vertueuse vertueux même pas
amoureuse ça encore lé ba oui oui pis ça
durera non non j'ai honte ou non alors
ça je trouve révoltant qu'un gars aux
deux étages et avec sa situation prétend
de garder pour lui seule une créature
aussi exquise que delphine lansac
c'est révoltant évidemment fin j'ai mes
moments d'égarement comme tout le monde
mais enfin chez ma fille ce sont
vraiment des minutes qui se prolonge
enfin écoutez j'ai un compagnon et les
mois me sortir cette barre à cette
impasse c'est tout ça et si je la
prenais seul à seul pour la raisonner on
aimerait bien autre chose
chers amis je vous promets demande
occupée mehdi dont il serait peut-être
temps que vous songez à vous aviez vous
oubliez l'opéra nous avons le temps
voyant il faut trois minutes pour passer
ma robe
je ne tiens pas à arriver dans une salle
vide
vous avez que quand je sors quand je
sors je fais mes entrées j'ai oublié de
vous dire que nous avions rendez vous au
bar du ritz avec chouchou 1 1 il vient à
l'opéra avec nous ah non non non non ça
au cocktail non je ne crois pas qu'il
soit en humeur de supporter lucie de la
mer noire et s'étaient cachés avant ta
vie vous auriez peut tout de même de
donner un coup de fil pour me laisser me
préparer comment vous préparez que ce
soit avec joshua ou avec moi vous
n'aviez tout de même pas l'intention
d'aller à l'opéra en pyjama évidemment
je veux dire me préparer moralement
c'est un événement voilà 15 ans vont me
parler de lui vous n'avez jamais trouvé
le moyen de le présenter si mes
souvenirs sont exacts vous l'avez
rencontré il ya quelques années à
auteuil appuie enfin je ne suis que son
fonds des poux à la vérité
j'ai peur qu'il me plaisent pas peur
j'ai été déçu il est dix fois plus riche
que points seulement enfin chochoy est
un homme extrêmement occupés écoutez
depuis que je le connais que je
travaille avec lui c'est la seconde
soirée je méconnais de livres salir
toujours lui s est josiane pep annonça
ils sont en froid depuis qu'elle s'est
fait refaire le nez
il trouve à juste titre qu après tant
d'années de collage elle n'avait pas
besoin de se faire refaire le nez
enfin d en haut
1 néanmoins ni or enfin chochoy est très
triste et très sains mais dites moi cher
commente m combien y at-il de places
disponibles dans votre loge aka le
préfet la mise entièrement à ma
disposition
les royaumes j'ai comme l'intuition nous
allons avoir besoin de ces quatre places
comment ça eh bien vous oif et bancaire
françois et devinez qui fera votre ami
hugues j'espère au nom pas mon ami
huguette figurez vous
on prépare à tenir ma décapotable et
l'autre et c'est un vrai rayon de soleil
bonjour à couper je suis une bouche et
aux courtes un jus d'orange et après le
dot nourrir 8 à 6 le dodo à lhassa ça
m'étonnerait même si la part ça fait
beaucoup de peine à tour part parce que
ton parent a plus de faire ce soir
un cadeau ça attendez avant de remercier
alabama je trouve que c'est un très très
beau cadeau bon alors voilà enfin est-ce
que vous allez nous faire droguer
pendant dix heures
ça commence à venir régulièrement votre
histoire de cadeau il ya voilà donc par
un temps froid ce soir à et qu'est-ce
que j'en ferais c'est trop non voilà les
réponses mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce
genre etc et spiritueux le dos je sais
pas quand quelque chose depuis modeste
par exemple il décapite à eau tout
simplement depuis les fixes
on peut s'y tromper dit gourde attend
qu'elle tombe tout rôti drapeau jeta
décapotable faut la vérité je travaille
je travaille je bricole
enfin oui ou non est ce que tu nous
accompagne alors grâce au soir pas
question tu as tort ce sera une très
belle soirée de gala ah oui ça 2500
francs la place enfin pour ceux qui
payent lagarde to fail
bon enfin il me semble et ce serait bon
pour ton stand ea comme tu dis il y aura
des photographes non mais ça je vous
promets les gardes républicains à des
fonds non je me lève de bonne heure de
matin de bonne heure non mais est ce
qu'une femme sérieuse se lèvent de bonne
heure à une femme comptable se lèvent de
bonne heure pour aller porter des robes
qui ne sont même pas elle envahit les
jolies dents métier le matin mais je
crois que les mannequins de sexyback
l'après midi je ne suis plus mal car je
suis modèles model oui je protège mode
made
c'est assez fatigant c'est pas mal payés
pas mal payés
quelquefois c'est très amusant rhodia
par exemple cet après midi on l'a pris
les photos en extérieur sont loin devant
oui je porte un immense poids en faisant
blanc sub 15 millions le contraste est
saisissant
devant ces murs l'épreuve enfin si tu
très dangereux avec tous ses vols
cheville au un moment ça agace et
quelques ménagères elles nous ont jeté
des épluchures et des trognons june and
roll off quand je pense qu'un tournage
était déjà marié veux remercier divorce
est entretenu par un financier belge est
sur le point de lever le pied avec un
pêcheur c'est quand même formidable de
vouloir à tout prix faire de moi une
grue une grue m'a alors dit aussi que tu
considères comme une grue non après tous
les sacrifices que j'ai fait pour elle
il ne faut jamais juger ses parents de
toute façon pour toi bel à fait
différente et une autre époque il aurait
pas pourquoi les moyen-âge non mais
regardez pas une ride et c'est ça et
c'est qu ici saskia comme ça je te donne
rendez vous dans vingt ans la petite
fille au bella je t'adore mais je ne
vois pas du tout l'avis de la même façon
c'est bien vrai alors tu ne lui
ressemble guère
non ça c'est tout le portrait peu de
cheveux courts merveilleux ça
m'étonnerait beaucoup mais enfin ma
petite chérie
il me semble pourtant avoir haussé dit
que le monde ait fait de 200 femmes et
raboteuse de chaussettes les pondeuses
tête rageuse de boutard et puis les
autres
les élus celle pour qui les hommes sur
huit de moins en mois d'ailleurs
ça c'est une pierre dans mon jardin la
porte un de nos jours c'est d'être
connue au la publicité ya que ça de vrai
après y'a plus qu'à choisir attend de
chant dans une carbo oui enfin film en
italie ou ambassadrice de la mode
française en amérique la gloire et
l'argent
et bah vous voyez belle laquelle est
plein de bonne volonté et ambitieuse
avec sa petite delphine si j'ai bien
compris tu arrivé mais sont couchés
exactement
l'orgueil de cette petite et ben moi
alors je te soutiens bien que le seul
royal arrivée pour une femme c'est
encore de prendre la main qu'est ce
qu'elle a dit elle est ok non j'ai dit à
mon mari va quoi tomber quoi ton mari
n'a pas faim tu parle toujours comme si
je n'étais pas marié il n'y a pas de
quoi se vanter
qu'est ce qui devient celui là toujours
aussi en grand nombre d'y tomber là tu
n'étais pas contre mon mariage il me
semble bah oui quoi il est bon pour une
femme qui a décidé d'arriver dans la vie
d'être lentilles d'avoir émis sa début
c'est pas une fin
personnellement je trouve très
désagréable de me prouver toujours nez à
nez avec ce blanc bec quand je vous
rends visite ma chair est blanche à une
langouste
alors je sais vraiment pas comment on va
prendre ça c'est vrai
la prochaine fois tu perds pas pour toi
ce genre de réflexion bon alors
qu'est-ce que vous décidez toutes les
deux alors que le film c'est bien décidé
que les sûr que tu préfère aller coucher
oui
paf il ya désormais ma petite fille
sache que je me désintéresse
complètement de toi m'enfin bella je ne
comprends pas tant pis c'est trop tard
patrouchev a battu pratique bon eh bien
maintenant puisque tout est réglé
allons-y faut pas faire un temps que son
choix
southwell perdu son choix évidemment
change pas mon papa joue cela le vrai
changement et le sel de kroll unique pas
le son soit les 5 6
le chant joueurs et savon et les
premiers dotés d insecticide le choix
des films sont joints joshua les bazars
son choix lecture it course son choix 1
ça te dit quelque chose il vient ce soir
oui petit malheureuse changerait via il
fallait dire
alors ça la femme est vraiment un animal
déconcertant je suis je craignais tat
réaction c'est vrai ça que tu me crois
qu'il ne rien penser quand tu es aussi
farouche n'ont pas vaincu pense que
j'allais rater son choix mais si tu te
rends compte de toutes les possibilités
que sa mort voilà combien enfin la voilà
résonna fois l'aval du sang et bien
mesdames mesdames puisque tout est
arrangé je ne saurais trop vous engagez
à vous allez vêtir et pomponne mais
qu'est ce que je vais dire est qu'en
fait pas je m'en charge a gentiment
alors le pot lui qui pensait enfin
passer une soirée tranquille avec vous
avez tout à vis de vos crédits je suis
étonné qu'il soit pas encore là mais qui
rendent toujours directement du bureau
répondre aux allégations plus tard
allant de faire un masque blanc leur
soutien dans le frigidaire de molène
guerre surtout laisse moi j'y vais mais
en tout bien tout honneur c'est ma
carrière qui est en jeu
parce était moyenne donc j'espère que
joshua sera bien au rendez vous parce
qu'il avait dit ça un peu en l'air ou
alors ça vous fait ce coup là non non
non non non mais ne vous inquiétez pas
chers amis ne vous inquiétez pas et puis
n'oubliez pas n'oubliez pas qu'il ne
sait pas que votre fille est de la
partie 1 et j'ai bien l'impression d'un
fils de nous prend vous et moi que comme
pièce restant m'a dit d'en parler pour
vous prouver que je m'en donne la peine
si je voulais s'éclipsera encore ma
fille j'entends la porte de
l'appartement se gâter votre jardin
c'est lui là faut toujours qu'il arrive
quand on n'a pas besoin de lui
nous n'allons pas vous mangez bonsoir mr
comolli est au pardon c'est vrai nom va
jamais à vous appeler par votre prénom
l'amap l'époque bonsoir jeune homme a
permettez moi de vous faire remarquer
qu'il ne faut jamais porter une cravate
régate avec un costume rayé j'ignorais
merci de le signaler
savez mon genre on n'impose pas au
dehors dit ça fait jeune finn et la dame
où je crois qu'elle est dans la salle de
bains elle prend sa douche
bah oui sans doute parce que c'est à
part toi non merci non me restait cinq
minutes avec nous voyons on vous voit
jamais nous avons déjeuné ensemble
aujourd'hui même
voyez comme tous les jours je veux dire
on vous voit jamais en dehors des repas
à si vous avez envie de me voir en
dehors des repas
ben oui comme ça en passant huit vous en
faut les explications non non c'est très
gentil
je vais juste prévenir delphine que je
suis rentré je suis avec blessés dont
delphine tranquille à la part de soi
nous vous voyons vous la verrez tout
ailleurs bon permettez je reviens tout
de suite ouais m mes pantoufles
j'ai de nouveaux souliers qui me blesse
et où seront tellement pantoufles dans
la salle de bain j'en étais sûr et bien
puisque vous souciez vous blesse pour
attirer les ici ben oui pourquoi pas il
est tellement plus simple que j'aille
dans la salle de bain et que je mette
mais pour tous et la sphère de deux
secondes alors si on enlevait le soulier
est probant
vous croyez vraiment oui le choc jean
fenouil ouellet au soulier aussi chez un
grand ami puisque ça le gêne
le jean louis soulié bah oui on en
mangerait pas enfin je suis très à
l'aise j'ai dit là c'est curieux
vraiment comme vous autres hommes
vous manquez de naturel qu'on ne vend
pas qu'il faut le garder ici jusqu'à ce
que delphine soit 30 tonnes et une fois
n'est pas coutume qu'est ce que c'est
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme on vous dit
elles sont allées vous me cacher quelque
chose me faire retirer mes souliers au
milieu du salon et me faire un verre de
porto s'est pas catholique
quelle nature anxieux les ouïes égalé
vives mais non sérieux mais tous ses
plans bull ne manon ce rien n'est pas la
conscience tranquille et la mort doit
arriver à 8 heures du soir et le film
s'est inquiété de mon retard observé
delfin société à c'est pas dans son
caractère
d'habitude je suis de retour vers 7h15
et 7h25 si je rate ma correspondance
ouais je crois que vous l'avez raté une
fois pour tous de votre correspondance
mon pauvre ami
le métropolitain est un moyen de
transport extrêmement comme ça je vous
jure qu'il faut que je rentre je
regrette d'avoir limouzy les chauffe et
bien moi je me flatte dit avoir jamais
mis les pieds dans le métro un même
pendant l'occupation il ya il ya dix ans
va circuler à vélo tous les jours je
remets pour voir le patron comme ce soir
il était encore dans son bureau je me
suis décidé tout de même depuis temps je
vais sans tarder
alors il ay d'aimables savez ce n'est
pas le genre d'homme aimable bombay
alors dites moi alors je lui ai remis ma
lettre de démission de démissionner
alors c'est une tactique pour les
impressionner à mais ça l'a impressionné
oui encore assez je crois je relaie
étaient sûrs alors c'est réglé a
définitivement mais je veux de la vie
m'ont maîtresse avant six mois parce que
ça va lui si
une fois mais pas deux mois mon dieu je
vous aurais foutu à la porte mais c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait commencez à ils ont
accepté votre démission sans aucune
difficulté
je croyais qu'ils se tenir au seul
croyez aussi
ouais enfin si vous occupez autant de
places au bureau qu'à la maison on doit
pouvoir se passer facilement de vous et
j'ai suivi vos conseils
bien m'en a pris eh ben c'est ça du tout
de suite que c'est ma faute je ne
regrette rien toute façon se
trouveraient toujours aussi bien
mais naturellement rien ne presse vous
êtes nord j'ai nourri blanchi la belle
île quoi vous auriez tort de ne pas en
profiter vous entendre madame on se
demanderait lequel de nous deux se fait
entretenir est vraiment lié à ça j'ai un
grand ami et j'ai pas très bien suivi la
conversation
je vous rappelle que vous êtes ici chez
moi monsieur lui pour longtemps madames
à l'appui le temps qu'on me le répéter
votre appartement
vous le trouverez sous les ponts vous
oubliez même que je vous paie une
pension mensuelle alors là parlons ça si
je vous conte est et et serviettes de
toilette que vous m'avez bousiller pour
essuyer de vos lames de rasoir et vos
trois morceaux de sucre dans le café et
ma petite bergère hausse atteint souvent
un complètement foutu parce que vous y
poser la tête avec votre salle pour une
briand qui non mais sans blague
à lombez la voyons vous vous échauffer
je vous remercie madame d'avoir fait une
fille qui ne vous ressemble pas le
grossier personnage
revêtez vos souliers monsieur toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est là où je te plaît qu'est ce que tu
fais dans cette tenue
comment mais là tu avais expliqué j'ai
décidé d'emmener ces dames à l'opéra se
distraire un peu si tu veux venir
tu es invité naturellement bassetto
sous-entendu si c'était page et à 30 m
il n'a même pas les smokings
alors tu me laisses tomber encore mon
papa qui corvée et pas moyen d
entraînement il m'avait promis cette
soirée qu'est ce que tu veux on fait pas
toujours ce qu'on veut il était drôle
c'est très important
j'ai moi aussi quelque chose de très
important à te dire pour moi qui sait de
quoi il s'agit je t'assure ma petite
fille que ça peut attendre un petit va
dîner bien tranquillement et tu liras
tard vue géographique dans ton lit j'ai
d'avoir là sur le bateau de l'entrée
mais vous pourrez d'ailleurs bien
tranquillement sans personne pour me
générant vert je ne sais pas ce que je
donnerai pour être à votre place mon
cher
je veux que delphine reste avec moi ce
soir d'un jeune à delphine va enlever
cette robe tout de suite bien croyez
vous parlez vous à une esclave les
femmes got 2 luv j'ouvre un siège à
l'assemblée nationale ils vous envoient
au bas faut-il que j aie moi même ou
dois-je te déshabiller de force au
milieu du salon à mon projet puisque tu
le prends sur ce point là j'irai quand
van eeckhout delphine un jour tu me
poussera tentées tant que je finirais
par donner une bonne fessée c'est tout
ce que tu mérites au l'affreux vous ne
frappe pas une femme même avec une euros
vous bouclez là un vieux crabes
alors là il faudrait savoir ces crabes
ou langouste c'est moi qui me suis
trompé par la toujours dit les femmes
delphine 20 dans ta chambre tout de
suite francophone dure cette voie comme
un tutu un évêque à la religion
maintenant on va vous l'avez bien élever
votre fille je vous en félicite madame
mais moi je mourrai pris ce monsieur et
vos félicitations je ne l'aimé où je
pense
offre vous vous décidez allez vous
habiller alors je te donne cinq minutes
pour me demander pardon
après je te préviens ça sent la corrida
des films ne me cherche pas ceux-ci
calme le tracas excessivement calme mais
je sens que je vais m'énerver
oulala doit accorder des héros il ya
longtemps que j'ai dépassé le stade des
ennuis ce titre m a dit je dramatise
depuis ce soir je suis sur le pavé sans
situation pas un sou devant moi obligés
de partager un appartement de poules
avec une foule qui est ma belle-mère et
qu'ils me traitent comme le dernier des
derniers marié à une créature frivole et
égoïste qui s'apprêtent pour l'opéra
abandonnant devant un dîner composé de
reste plus ou moins réchauffé commencé
revient demain parce que je les aurais
refusé comme la veille affligé d'un
furoncle dans le coup torturé par une
paire de souliers neufs qui semble
rétrécir usages et tu oses me dire que
je dramatise non alors reprenons tout
cela méthodiquement tu verras ce n'est
pas si grave que ça en a l'air
mais me fait pas rire prime tu as perdu
des situations bon c'est embêtant mais
comme tu te bénis tout le temps ce sera
au moins déjà ça de gagné évidemment
c'est une façon de voir les choses
secundo l'appartement ils ne te plaît
pas cet appartement non à moi non plus
je n'aime que le style anglais te de
quoi payer une reprise bon alors bouclée
là quand mon cousin daniel s'est marié
il nous a très gentiment proposé de
reprendre le sien un entresol sur courts
porte d'orléans ça n'avait rien de plus
excitant
évidemment ce n'était pas le genre
affinée de ta main à tertio maman je
t'aime et redit de traiter maman de
poule
maintenant est une femme qui a beaucoup
souffert
ça va se faire consommer mais pas tant
que ça elle n'a jamais eu qu'un seul à
avoir la foi
quarto quatrièmement qu'est ce que c'est
déjà je grille et créatures frivole et
égoïste au camp je pense que j'ai pris
la peine de te préparer moi même ton riz
au lait avec des raisins encore un oui
monsieur oui avec des raisins de
corinthe parfaitement
cinquièmement confieront khl ce soir je
te mettrai un pansement humides et de
maïs ramure quant à des souliers
s'étoffer moitié je viens de les
remettre
tu vois tu aime souffrir bon c'est
décidé nous allons changer de vie oui
oui j'accepte ce poste qu'on va proposer
dans une affaire d'exportation poussa à
tananarive
oui évidemment tananarive tu ne pensez
tout de même pas que j'allais me
contenter toute ma vie d'un poste de
sous fifres à la compagnie des chargeurs
réunis
oui mais en fait tout ça c'est le passé
fait une croix dessus avant de
s'embarquer pour tananarive vous pourrez
peut-être essayer de trouver quelque
chose afin dit on qui ont donc parlera
peut-être à beaune empêche que si tu
avais été un peu plus gentil avec lui
c'est un homme calme bras long mais
surtout quand il s'agit d'aller réparer
et à fermeture éclair ou d'aller
chercher dans son corsage telles
médailles de première communion à sous
prétexte d'en déchiffrer l'inscription
comment fais tu poses b qui sait très
bien ce qu'elle écrit dessus c'est lui
qui me l'a donnée si tu peux avoir de
mauvaises pensées je ne veux rien devoir
aux amis de ta mère ni à personne
d'ailleurs un des principes pareil tu
iras loin c'est par les gens qu'on
arrive je déteste les gens cités qui
vient scénario non comme ça tout d'un
coup n'importe qui peut écrire un
scénario
cela risque reporter modéliste
photographe voila voila députés qui
marche ou des chapeaux t'as pas envie
tirs des chapeaux alors si tu crois que
je suis passé paris sciences politiques
que j'ai fait une licence d'espagnol et
deux années de droit pour faire des
chapeaux tu es incapable du moindre
sérieux je partage pas une seconde mais
souci les angoisses tu parle pour ne
rien dire
préoccupée uniquement de ta coiffure de
ta robe est ton décolleté tu l'as
remarqué ça fait la grimace
bah évidemment pour moi même plus
delphine est donc décidé à y aller tu
vas pas mon cerveau caprice ne me dis
pas que c'est pour la musique jamais été
capable de reconnaître au clair de la
lune de la marseillaise
c'est qu'ils viennent il faut raison la
calb en dieu laquelle sinon cette
maladie de sortir ne te produire toutes
affiché partout n'importe où et à tout
prix nous écoute mon ami met toi bien à
la fête une chose c'est que je gagne ma
vie notre vie
à partir de ce soir et comme mon métier
que tu veuilles ou non consiste à me
montrer c'est dégoûtant s'exhibe en
maillot de bain dans des concours de
beauté sordide tu fait des pieds et des
mains pour être invité au gala au
festival tu te pousse pas de
photographier aux côtés de vedettes et
de personnages du célèbre qui ne te
connaissent même pas n'empêche que teddy
rudement fier quand tes collègues ou
reconnus aux actualités entre est donné
le signal de départ de la course
cycliste paris va dans le mur et dont tu
as tout fait tout essayé tout sauf le
suicide et la gac ans mais la faute à
qui oui il ya beaucoup de choses tu sais
auquel se relance à cause de toi mais
autrement dit je suis une entrave à ta
carrier je ne reproche pas certain que
si je n'étais pas marié les choses
seraient plus faciles on va divorce ma
chère tu n'a tout de même pas la
prétention de me garder enfermés depuis
ressortir dans la rue avec un voile sur
la figure comme et fatma si nous étions
à bagdad au caire le voyage comprend
maintenant pourquoi tous voulaient
m'emmener à tananarive ignorante avec ça
tu feras mieux lire un peu plus souvent
méranville géographique au lieu de ton
ciné magazine
oui ça je ne suis pas comme toi la
science infuse j'en ai assez de films je
ne veux plus que tu te déshabille en
public que tu te lave les dents sur un
écran publicitaire que tu te pousse que
tu te touche pour être photographiés au
côté de jean j'en ai assez dit moi qui
n'aime que toi au monde
moi qui n'ai jamais trompé tu te trompes
avec ton miroir tu me trompes ait europe
tu me confonds avec toi même enfin
comment peut-il que ce thème il m'arrive
de te souhaiter un accident d'automobile
dans lequel tu serais défiguré à ce
moment là je serai le seul voilà comment
je voudrais tu m'aimes bien mou ce
serait que tu m'aimes trop tu m'aimes
mal comme moi je t'aime
delphine ne pleure pas la raison je dois
être un monstre
trop exigeant trop exclusif mais j'ai si
peur de perdre si tu savais comme j'ai
peur alors j'ai besoin de te faire
pleurer
cela me rassure donc pas longtemps il
suit tes larmes remets ta petite mèche
c'est fini tout recommence mon
maquillage du foot
on s'en va les filles invalidante et
fraîche toi ça te réussit les tête à
tête avec ton mari j je vais me
reprendre et dans la voiture joshua
n'attend pas dans 130 amis vous avez
pris vos précautions me faites par le
coup de deux ou trois jours à la
générale des ambassades vertes ou bien
les émotions
nous irons soupe et après les spectacles
j'ai bien servi de langoustes au pardon
grave pas langoustes j'ai mis ton pyjama
en salle alors tu entendras un prof dans
l'eau de l'armoire et puis oui j'ai déjà
lu mélo change aussi alors surtout sois
gentille
quand tu auras fini de faire sa toilette
n'oublie pas de fermer cumulus voilà
qu'est ce que je voulais dire encore
baissé c'est tout pendant mon chéri je
t'en peux pas tester pastèque moi ce
soir mon feu tu sais très bien que c'est
impossible je t'en supplie non pas
pourquoi parce que je te demande si tu
m'aimes d'hommes qui passe ce soir où tu
tu ne sais pas l'enfant de taille fine
si tu m'abandonnes sociaux je ne sais
pas ce qui va se passer mais moi je sais
très bien tu vas dîner bien
tranquillement tu diras tu as revue
géographique dans ton lit et quand je
rentrerai je trouverais endormi bien
simple
delphine pour la dernière fois j'espère
qu'il sera calmée belle fille
interurbain je voudrais leur haute
savoie le 15 à chambéry combien de temps
oui ici maillot 18-20 mrc j'adore
monsieur
qu'est ce que vous voulez peut servir
monsieur vous occupez pas de moi alors
j'attends je n'ai pas faim monsieur bête
ne lui prépare un sandwich qui reste
dollars et au beurre noir d'avant-hier
midi
non merci alors je peux monter oui et le
plus haut possible
monsieur permet que je prenne un bouquin
dans la bibliothèque de la série noire à
pâlir la nuit y'a rien de tel pour faire
dormir mais si vous voulez merci
monsieur pas si j'avais su que ce rallye
de si bonne heure ce soir sera la baie
coucher ma belle soeur on la fait
tourner soir votre belle soeur dans un
film ballon pour ma belle soeur la table
allo chambéry maman c'est huguette en
fils plus tu vas bien épais ah pardon
c'est vrai ah oui vous coucher de bonne
heure bon ben je me dépêche
voilà j'ai une grande nouvelle je
reviens chez toi pas à la maison chez
nous non non je reviens seul nom j'ai
fait quelques jours de vacances alors
j'en profite à ben tout de suite à ce
soir par le premier train avant
évidemment ça tombe mal
et dans la petite chambre du grenier les
pommes de terre avait alors chez la
tante suzanne vous êtes enfant
j'aurais tellement aimé vous revoir tous
deux militants oui mais c'est ça la
prochaine fois je t'écrirai serait de
savoir plus tôt
je t'embrasse très fort ma petite mort
si elle que qu'est ce que vous voulez
encore
senna besoin de rien non je voulais déjà
dit ça a pas l'air d'aller vous de ce
qui vous regarde on se compte en
dizaines vers le bar pourquoi me
demandez-vous sont pas des fois que
monsieur vous de respect réchauffer
quelque chose un peu plus tard
foutez moi la paix vous avez compris
le bec à vie dure à cuire comme ces
types du bouquin que vient de prendre
dans la bibliothèque que monsieur ne
cherche pas or encore monsieur voudrais
servir de l'objet je le préviens il
marche pas je l'essayé sur shah de la
concierge monsieur
telle maison est même plus moyen de se
tuer tranquille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suis dit qu'il valait mieux en avoir le
coeur net alors je les fais ma balise
j'ai pris mon billet de chemin de fer et
me voilà je suis désolé madame vraiment
de vous recevoir lors ce salon fermé aux
visites pour l'hiver si j'avais pu me
doutais et je vais vous auriez dû nous
prévenir on serait venu vous chercher un
taxi à la gare inutile ma fille je ne
veux surtout déranger personne
après une mue en chemin de terre dont
les éprouvettes besoin vous rafraîchira
je peux faire un brin de toilette fait
je sentirai geoffrey soit pas une telle
pensée à l'eau allant droit au but je ne
suis pas venue de chambéry pour faire
des manières
que s'est il passé exactement je n'ai
rien compris à vos lettres ma fille
truffer les fautes d'orthographes
d'ailleurs alors racontez moi tout en
ordre
depuis le début et bien voilà aussi
extraordinaire que cela puisse paraître
il y aura 4 e 10 as même pas veulent
plus des disparus
comment ça a disparu aucune trace il n'a
laissé aucune trace
ce soir là nous étions allés l'opéra
avec maman est parent hughes avait
refusé de nous accompagner selon son
habitude lors comme il était assez tard
oui nous étions allés sous presse ou
paie un peu le spectacle je me suis
rentré dans sa chambre je me suis
déshabillée dans le mois qu'on ne pas le
réveiller
c'est alors que je m'approchais lui tout
doucement pour l'embrasser pas sur ma
fille y passe
je me suis aperçu que sa place était
vide plus du n'avait-il pas léger à
billets mais rien toutes ces affaires
étaient là il est parti les mains vides
comme il était venu et depuis mais
depuis aucune nouvelle et le droit à la
parole
merci vous pensez bien voilà que tout ce
qui est humainement possible de faire
pour le retrouver a été tentée je les
habille très important la préfecture qui
se sont mis je dois dire en 10 pour
mettre agréable sans aucun résultat
ok je pense qu'on ne saurait dre voilà
d'avoir fait en sorte que le secret le
plus absolu était gardé jusqu'à présent
sur cette affaire votre mari vous juger
nous-mêmes ne vont tout mettre en oeuvre
pour éviter le scandale
certes et je suis ravi de vous
l'entendre dire bien que fait vous
madame
cette aversion soudaine pour le scandale
me paraissent un peu tardive
j'espérais à un moment que mon mari sera
chambéry hélas non bien que lui
manifester la velléité dû rentrer dans
le syntras familles ravies
oui je fais le rapprochement avec
certains coups de téléphone
si je ne m'abuse le torchon brûlait dans
le ménage comme on dit il était assez
ombrageux ces derniers temps plutôt
difficile ne lui donnez vous pouvez les
raisons de l'être cela ne le regarde pas
mais je n'en mettrais pas ma main ouf
comme on l'a conduite de ma fille était
très proche à bhl duo mortiers ou qu'il
disponibles ne saurait en douter
réfléchissons bien que cette éventualité
ne répugnant envisagée mais après tout
étant donné le milieu la chose n'est pas
impossible
monfils n'aurait-il pas eu disons le mot
une maîtresse une fois vous ne pensez
pas ajouté phil hay live et goûter à
vrai dire je ne le crois pas il n'avait
ni les moyens ni la carrure avec les
hommes n'ont pas la main ne sais pas
c'est vous qui savez
il avait parlé à un moment de partir
pour tananarive nous voilà sur une piste
je fais alerté le gouverneur c'est dire
clairement et prévenu alors aux mets que
faire croire j'en peux plus j'ai déjà
perdu trois kilos faudra tout de même
être fixée pour le moment
ma fille est égaré par le chagrin enfin
nous sommes tous égards et par le
chagrin mais enfin delphine à la vivante
elle compte trois niemann coins de notre
côté quelques douloureuse que puisse
être cette supposition il y a certaines
initiatives certaines formalités
auxquelles nous devons commencer à
penser hughes avait douze frères et
soeurs vous comprenez mais les voûtes
erdre il n'est pas marine ne m'a pas
fait je suis excusé vous savez ce sont
ses nerfs qui la trahissent et puis
enfin si cette incertitude est très
fille
enfin pour moi la question ne fait pas
de doute bien sûr et je vois votre tenue
et madame vous partagez mon sombre
pressentiment depuis 30 ans madame je
porte le deuil en permanence dans l'eau
famille est là sa mort chasse l'autre la
renaissance est quoi il est à souhaiter
que que diligence soit fait pour
retrouver le corps
j'avais toujours prédit que ça se
terminerait pas voilà qu'il aura guère
donné de satisfaction à sa famille et
pourtant rien n'a été négligé pour son
éducation je vous prie de croire le juge
ne pas dîner pas lever à 5h30 en hiver à
5 heures en été comme six frères et
soeurs laver à l'eau froide bien entendu
et dormant dans un dortoir son chauffage
par nos plus rue jane savoyard aussi
jamais un rhume et une constitution
vigoureuse on l'aurait un mois né à 8
ans pensionnaire chez les jésuites où
ils ne sortaient que pour les grandes
vacances à ce moment-là nous l'envoyons
faire un stage à la ferme la vie saine
ouvrant tél
ça je veux dire que l'on rencontre de
ses frères et soeurs qui tenait du juge
hugues avait hérité de moisson l'exquise
sensibilité presque maladive
élève moyen il passera des examens
moyens avec tout juste la moyenne
pendant la guerre il fuit le maquis au
lieu des ponts et chaussées comme lui
conseiller son père il en revint soldat
de deuxième classe alors que loïc sont
au frère cadet qui avait sagement
attendu d'être appelée sous les drapeaux
nous ramener le fils est sous lieutenant
il n'a jamais été très débrouillard
après quoi ce furent c'est malencontreux
semaine de camping sur la côte
d'émeraude
vous voulez dire dinard où il a eu la
chance de rencontrer delphine dans les
dunes je crois après la bien fallu
réparer mais pareil mais qu'il n'avait
besoin d'aucune réparation
on se serait même beaucoup mieux réparer
tout ça qu'est ce que c'est une gare
quand on voit la même façon à l'entrée
des couronnes déjà chouchou moins encore
six pour delphine ces bordels sont
ramenées de nuit dans sa chambre royaume
y ait eu enfin madame je vais lever le
siège nous n'avons plus rien à lui dire
je passerai et dès aujourd'hui au
commissariat de police du quartier pour
faire la déposition au rêve
naturellement nous vous tiendrons au
courant
pouvez vous me dire d'où je peux envoyer
un télégramme pour annoncer mon retour
mais certainement il ya un bureau de
poste au coin de la rue en pourparler
déjà ces dames de l'ouvroir sont
surchargés de travail à la proche des
fêtes de noël du minois douloureuse mais
vaillants jeu très seraient des
guirlandes jeu puis seraient des
lanternes vénitiennes et j'ai fui
lâcherait les cheveux d'ange pour nos
chers petits orphelins
adieu madame bon ça
les gars là cette femme si le bon dieu
voulait me faire plaisir
leur rapide de chambéry des regrets ce
soir
mais je ne veux pas de ces fleurs dans
ma chambre monde sorti mon ange mal nous
allons sortir vainqueur fera du bien ces
fleurs je les déteste
tu entends bella je ne vaut plus rien
recevoir deux chouchous les fascine ma
petite fille qui le lui
je ne veux plus voir non plus menant au
score il eût mieux valu tout de suite
refusé son invitation de ce soir mais
c'est toi qui accepté en contrefaisant
mavs au téléphone j'ai entendu enfin
depuis le temps que tu le fais marcher
joshua il n'était en tout de même de lui
donner un petit encouragement tapote
coeur j'ai toujours dit non
cet homme est fou de toi là la merci
d'une attaque prêts à les décrocher la
lune
si tu le lui demandait tu crois mais
voyons j'ai vu tout de suite que tu le
tenait dès la première rencontre
c'est uniquement pour toi qui s'est
envoyé lucy lucy lucy de lammermoor
enfin qu'est ce que tu espères tout
faire une raison ou ma petite fille
comme bari 1
il est loin non mais tu crois qu'ils
auraient eu la délicatesse de fakoly la
correction de laisser un petit mot pour
nous dire qu'il allait se tuer je m'en
fiche
il était bien décidé à nous empoisonner
jusqu'au bout et au delà
tandis que lui reposait bien tranquille
pour l'éternité
il a su que la wii je le sent partout
dans cet appartement toujours présent
tiens la brûlure de cigarette sur la
dette chinoise
celui-ci ont battu ce fait les souvenirs
comme ça il en a laissé beaucoup dans la
maison vert sous le vernis s'est lui
aussi cette tâche d'encre sur le
secrétaire tu vois ça c'est le jour où
il a vu remplir son stylo des brûlures
des tâches des objets cassés et voilà
tout ce que cet arbre a laissé derrière
lui dans la salle de bal sa brosse à
dents est encore dans le vert son tube
de crème à raser sur l'étagère il me
semble qu'ils diminuent j'ai
l'impression qu'une main vient d'y
toucher de le déplacer imperceptiblement
ce qui prend de temps en temps à une
gare de la fantaisie de faire le ménage
parfois ce sont des gros je découvre des
traces de mousse encore humide
1 ça m'étonnerait tout de même que la
bonne phrase tu divagues je dorme
âge je me réveille en sursaut
j'entendais des bruits des craquements
bizarre quand même que je me décide à
prendre un chat j'ai des cauchemars je
rêve qu'on entre dans ma chambre est
nombreuse moi je suis moi nous donner la
chair de poule avec ou tennis toi c'est
pas avoi la parole ne montre pas cette
figure lui qui vient ici pour se
distraire
mesdames je vous pèsent les mains un
petit tel film j'ai pensé à vous en
passant place de la madeleine
je vous apporte des doutes mais si vous
me regardez pas gêner rouge
vous allez nous accompagner à
l'exposition canine ça vous remontera le
moral et on l'a mais nous avons d'autres
plans nous allons aller au commissariat
de police du quartier pour la déposition
vous savez quoi je vous accompagne ça
fera plusieurs moines ou renault si on
attendait encore après jusqu'à demain
mais temps avec elle nous ferait avoir
des ennuis en fait je ne sait déjà pas
comment vous allez expliquer ce silence
prolongé leurs relations entre ce que
dit parra ou en groupe on voit alors le
temps de passer à moto qu israël vient
au centre bell
à la rose que c'est bien quelqu'un j'ai
un grand tapis la fournée quoi nous
attendons nous sommes prêts et la voilà
voilà j'arrive
dix fois
[Applaudissements]
ainsi que les réponses enfin ça y est on
est tranquille quel temps fait-il ça y
est quand on pense que les gens se
produisaient de sortir sous la pluie
dans le vent dans le froid les fous
qu'est ce que vous m'avez préparer de
bons pour le déjeuner de la tarte à
l'oignon des rites vous à la quine
champagne c'était la dernière bouteille
tant pis et des mousses au chocolat pain
fromage du beurre d'auvergne bien fait
comme vous l'aimez vous me soigner ça
vous change un jeune sans pleine forme
ce matin
quoi de neuf on a eu la visite vous avez
entendu les vagues bang au début se
tendaient l'oreille je voulais savoir ce
que l'on disait de moi maintenant suis
trop occupé pour perdre mon temps avec
toutes ces balivernes
elle les journées passent si vite tiens
à propos vous mme apporterez le deuxième
tome des essais de montaigne sur le
premier rayon de la bibliothèque
comme montaigne et dire que je ne
l'avais jamais lu dépêchez vous savez
refroidir installez-vous et demi c'est
pas possible on dirait que mais oui vous
prononcer
mais j'ai retrouvé j'ai retrouvé dans le
placard là une lampe à rayons
ultraviolets qui devait appartenir à
delphine je m'en sers ce que vous êtes
devenu beau frapper tard non non et non
je veux pas m'en passer
monsieur va pouvoir prendre un bain ce
soir ces dames sont de sortie vous me
demandez pas où elles vont c'est
l'importance dîners en ville et avec qui
chauffent moins il entend envoyer une
grande corbeille de fleurs cet après
midi ça fait combien de temps exactement
que je me suis retiré 44 jours fait une
croix tous les matins sur mon calendrier
ça diraient pas 1 44 jours
elle aura donc refusé 43 dîner c'est
beaucoup
elles sont allées au commissariat avec
le parrain parle rt la police ils vont
peut-être faire une enquête est alors
site oui la maison et qui vous trouvent
ici un nouvel onglet pour exercer dans
la champ non ce serait pas la même chose
dans les films de gangsters
il est excellent ce fromage vous savez
les choisir y a pas que le fromage
immédiat c'est un petit placement et la
fin
mens pas la fin non non je n'ai pas
songé
c'était violent et moi monsieur oui
c'était 8 les brus j'en connais des
courriers avec un grand bien et plein de
ça fait une belle boulette
alors vous pensez désir de l'homme chez
ce que c'est vrai non merci dense et
très gentil mais pas pour le moment huit
photos en attendant retrait mois la
donne que je vous fais du plateau
ensuite je sais pas quand on rame ya la
cuisine prenait 2 avec vous oh non pitié
quoi encore
pattesbleues domergue
tant pis
une envie de ma fille j'ai oublié mon
parapluie il doit être dans le salon ah
le voilà c'est un très beau parra puis
je n'avais aucune raison d'en faire
cadeau à votre patronne bon bah vous
n'avez rien il est doux parce que c'est
pas tout ça mais j'ai lu enfin vint clé
ma fille bac et je trouve même que vous
en prenez à votre aise si vous étiez ça
mon service c'est à nous ne l'ont pas
rentrer sitôt aux patrouilles le contre
un peu étonné je crois même que c'est
pas la peine de les attendre vous
permettez pécore que je retrouve mon
souffle j'ai des chevilles enflées
d'ailleurs mon train de pinte à 11h40
il est 4h justement j'ai tout mon temps
allez allez vous encore votre cuisine si
j'y suis
d'ailleurs la famille s'installe un
charmant quoi je veux bien plus de père
a marqué mais qu'il a réussi tout est
nouveau venu
sonia deux mois vous allez rater ça je
suis désolé de vous encombrer ma
présence madame sort mais pas le moins
du monde madame avec le président je ne
le gêne pas apparemment mes hommages
madame mal à müller la maman de notre
cher disparu
vous trouvez toujours le mot juste pas
d'armes c'est triste à dire mais depuis
que la déposition est fait je me sens un
peu moi c'est la ville en porte toujours
bien négligeait ta carrière tu vois ces
derniers temps si seulement je pouvais
avoir un contrat pour hollywood ça
m'aiderait oublier ans mais je vais
changer de maquillage de coiffure de
style
une des filles nouvelle qui ne
ressemblera plus en rien à ce que le
pauvre hugh et mais ce sera ma façon à
moi de rester fidèle cette petite a de
bien jolis chants tilman ne trouvez-vous
par madame
et bien voilà on est tous réunis sont
analysés comme après un enterrement
la veuve et en rouge c'est a prévu bon
c'est vrai qu'elle fait pour sacha
cornes
vous vous trouvez vraiment pas
évidemment n'est ce pas d'ailleurs et il
ya le plus saignant que le noir vous
même j'ai ramé le portier ha'avir un
jour ou encore à l'enterrement du major
si belle dans vos voiles s'éclipser
laveur elles ont pleuré de rage mais il
semblerait plus fort on s'entendait plus
dans l'église et quand le fou rire s'en
est mêlée alors
fou rire nerveux bien entendu alors
qu'est ce que je vais mettre votre
commande et un trousseau
ah oui des dessous en chantilly noir
alors d'autres choses non mais imagine
imaginables une veuve qui retire sa robe
sur d'une agence de quoi aurais tu l'air
est édifiant mais en attendant et ben
attend c'est pas moi je crois que les et
j'ai gardé quelque part les voiles dans
un carton et si je ne m'abuse dans ce
cas car tiens ils sont pas brûlés puis
vous on va regarder tout de suite comme
ça pour aller porter dès ce soir
tiens les comment se fait-il qu'il n'y
ait pas la clim garde au avec cette
maison est tenu en dépit du bon sens
vous êtes deux forment pourtant avec
cette fille devient absolument
impossible en vérifiant les comptes du
mois je me suis aperçu que je faisais
drôlement mal s'élance du panier et puis
7 cette manie de laisser là la porte de
la cuisine mais on met ça empeste dans
ce salon
or à eux mêmes à damas a appelé way we
la clé du placard
quel plat car le cac a répondu
des perdus alors ça c'est un sens c'est
pareil tout ce que vous attendiez pour
faire venir les erreurs liées et qui
adore languedoc et en prime on vous
demande pas votre ami se trouve que
justement j'avais quelque chose à y
rechercher voyez dans quel embarras vous
nous mettez ça fait rien et la [ __ ]
moi tu sais quand je veux quelque chose
moi c'est tout de suite
bon bah vais la chercher la clé mais ça
va prendre du temps
bah les hippies ramenez-nous serrurier
immédiatement au vif il ya six à mons où
sont mes clés de petites jeunettes
ce serait bien le diable qui ne
conviennent
c'est moi tout est fermé à clé le la
déconfiture
c'est ce que j'appelle tenir une besson
voyons ça peut ne voudrait pas mais
qu'est ce qui lui prend qui est étrange
c'est pourquoi ils me gardent ça je
n'aime pas du tout ces animaux là le
livre la balle ou les excès a mis à bas
les talons et le parapluie à l'époque
trois sous ion l'autre place cela ne va
pas aller et si dans une autre a de quoi
je crois qu'en forçant un peu si la
bonne nouvelle là
un homme dans le placard bien cette
optique qu'est ce que tu fais dans ce
placard petit galopin vous attendiez pas
trouvé non mais je rêve ils pas c'est
une plaisanterie de très mauvais goût
mais d'abord il vous a permis de mettre
mon vieux kimonos me faire venir des
chapélies pour une partie de cache cache
pas je trouve ça un peu raide
vous allez bien tous depuis le temps
qu'on fait en sorte crois que j'ai plus
qu'à retourner dans la cuisine on les
attendait dans une minute vous j'ai
besoin de vous étiez vous ne serez pas
prêt non il ne garde pas fait comme
meilleure maison mais dites donc vous
mettiez viable la tarte à l'oignon de la
mousse au chocolat feria avec sa vie'
vous là qu'ils savaient même pas faire
fuir à l'offre plus mes jours au 8 mai
complètement docteur une balle perdue
taloche place qu'ils méritent
bon allez laissez nous seuls je veux
rester seul avec une en super mais
semble important que nous avons notre
couette
c'est très imprudent et peut-être
dangereux ou non non non je vous en prie
tous et vous voyez pas donner trop
qu'est ce que vous attendez
les deux assis sur le garde-manger
vous savez nous ne sommes pas à ça près
et bien alors norme au boudoir puisque
on nous chasse
nous y serons tous prêts pour besoin
appelé police secours
croyez moi d'être bon au toujours qu'ils
nous donnent de fausses joies à celui là
[Applaudissements]
dis moi quelque chose oui mais chez ben
c'est bête mais je ne trouve rien et
puis tant qu'on ne s'est pas vu tu sais
pour moi le temps ça ne signifie plus
grand chose quand il y en a d'autres
pour qui cinq semaines ça signifie un
certain nombre de jours et pas mal de
nuits blanches qui refuse de croire pas
d'où je reviens tout reviens tu de loin
de très loin de très loin
exagère
j'ai fait un grand voyage delphine un
grand voyage en moi même tu es sûr que
tu te sens tout à fait bien à nous
rassure toi je ne suis pas fou tu vas
pas me dire que d'aller s'enfermer dans
un placard c'est une idée qui viendra
quelqu'un de normal tu n'as jamais eu
envie peu enfermé dans un placard
j'ai réfléchi bien alors c'est toi qui
est anormal tout le monde a eu dans son
existence plus ou moins l'envi de
s'enfermer dans un placard
tu crois dans tes jeux d'enfants lorsque
tu te cacher sous un lit ou dans un
recoin de cagibi recroqueviller sur toi
même bien au chaud invisible c'était pas
merveilleux d'entendre les autres qui te
cherchais dans l'appartement où la bonne
affolé kit appelait les toits de ne pas
répondre je ne jouais pas quand j'étais
petit on empêcher d'aller avec les
autres enfants à moi au collège pendant
l'étude du soir je demandais à sortir
jallet m'enfermer dans les cabinets pour
rêver un bon raconte qui restait des
heures tel un roi sur son trône je le
sais par coeur tu vois des fines
ce qui nous pousse vers l'est les
cabinets les débarras les placards c'est
cet instinct animal de la tanière ont
peut-être inconsciemment ce désir callum
de revenir d'où il vient dans le ventre
de sa mère tu veux revenir dans le
ventre de tannay bava c'est une image de
mauvais coups tout cela est très joli et
les gens ont peu une envie folle de
s'enfermer dans les placards mais eux
ils ne font pas simplement parce qu'ils
n'ont jamais eu l'occasion
parce que ce n'est ni d'occasions on
doit peut-être venu tu me la donnez un
peu facile
un certain soir que je me sentais
vraiment très seul et malheureux
j'étais supplier de rester tu es sorti
je touchais le fond du désespoir
ce soir là j'ai voulu me tuer oui et
puis j'ai réfléchi je me suis dit qu'au
fond l'idée n'était peut-être pas si
bonnes mais d'abord c'est très compliqué
de se tuer ensuite on risque de se faire
mal tu sais comme je suis maladroit mais
enfin pour être franc je ne veux pas
entièrement l' envie de me tuer ce que
je voulais surtout c'était un bta voilà
j'imaginais tu es là en meute et
remporte à coller une fois mort cela me
faisait de belles jambes tu me suis je
devance jonathan demme au tournant
l'idée m'est donc venu de faire le mort
d'assister caché aux douze spectacles de
ton chagrin
j'ai bien pensé aussi à partir pour
tananarive à m'exiler mais vivant je ne
pouvais me résoudre à l'idée de
m'éloigner de toi non je t'assure que
c'était de bon coup la meilleure
solution de beaucoup alors sans argent
sans but humilié bafoué racheter de
toutes parts j'échoue est dans ce cas
j'y vais et je me tairai comme une bête
traquée blessé à mort au début ça a été
pénible ne le cache pas j'avais des
crampes des fourmis dans les jambes
un [ __ ] sincérité me bouleversait cent
fois j'ai eu envie de sortir et de me
jeter à tes pieds pour te demander
pardon mais qui l'a pas fait une nuit
même ni résistants plus j'ai réussi à me
glisser jusqu'à ta chambre j'étais
regarder dormir alors ça c'est mal à et
si je m'étais réveillé vous faire des
peurs pareil et puis les jours ont passé
je me suis organisé une garde a été
parfaite s'agit de savoir apprendre
c'est tout tu assumes il faut quoi
sans elle je ne sais pas ce que je
serais devenu qui serait sorti du
placard
un peu plus tôt peut-être toujours envie
de mourir moi mais je commence à peine à
vivre
avant j'avais peur de tout tout le monde
voit c'est m'énervait paris son trafic
son bruit infernal sakho a eu dans le
métro la sonnerie du téléphone
les gros titres des journaux qui vous
êtes à la figure lors guère leurs bombes
leur beau quotidienne et puis tout à
coup le cas où le silence la paix
je goûte chaque minute au maximum les
bruits de la maison me parviennent
étouffés comme ceux d'une planète
lointaine microscopique comme à dieu le
père eh bien mon ami le roi n'est pas
ton posé mais enfin toutes proportions
gardées
qu'est ce que tu fais toute la journée
sur ton nuage
moi je lis j'écris je médite et moi
qu'est ce que je deviens moi toi mais je
continue ma chérie tu fais ce qu'il te
plaît
comme tu dis ça je ne me poserai plus à
ta carrière soit tranquille mais comment
tu n'es plus jaloux dans ma vie mais il
fau choix
il est pour mille de bella mais d'abord
attendu dans nos placards j'étais sûr
fois le cd tu sais j'ai confiance en toi
alors c'est une même plus mais au
contraire je t'aime mieux je t'aime pour
toi même avec tes qualités et tes
défauts je t'aime delphine et bien
j'aimais mieux quand tu m'aimais mal
lors du verre outre ces écoutes essayer
d'être encore un peu jaloux rien pour me
faire plaisir
non moi je te promets de vous coûter je
ferai ce qu'il faudra pour tt ce que son
ombre h sophie 6000 sont nerveux
j'sais pas moi disent plutôt non c'est
moi une scène robes à moi bah moi si tu
veux c'est simple bonheur tour est bien
avec un fou dans la maison ça
m'étonnerait nous prenons ces passeront
devant lui voyons j'ai signé avant
partis répondait bien une petite
collation
mais vous rêvez en nous laissant votre
cinglé de rocheteau sur les bras revenez
le nom à son very il est moins fort que
toi je lui disais déjà dit de ne pas
prononcer ce mot devant lui c'est un
créneau d'une pipe ciment office et dans
ce triste état je vous en tient pour
responsable mesdames alors delphine
s'est décidée tu divorces et tout de
suite on ne peut pas divorcé d'un f ont
eu du peu des commandes et surtout un
bel a surtout elle ne fait pas sa toile
il faut soigner mon fils par am je serai
bien vous auriez par devant ce tribunal
à nous verser une rente un examen
sanguin s'impose pour l'hérédité le
ménage chez madame que j'ai les plus
grandes à vacallo maman ça dans votre
lit un peu moins de bruit
c'est mon imprésario ou alors qu'on va
bien mais si vous continuez sur ce temps
madame je vous dis ça mais je servirai
de témoins en effet bien placer mon gros
loup nous l'a dit pato studio c'est
heureux le portant madame je proteste je
proteste même avec véhémence et
indignation fief rebelle et sacrifient
pour toi vous raccompagner dans ma la
madame qui aurait pu au moins respecter
ma project joli monde
ah oui c'est vrai il est parti il était
impossible qu'il soit sorti sans que
nous ayons vu le métro sont les plus sur
la serrure et alors il récidive
oh non c'est pas possible 8 s'est
enfermé dans un placard avec mon
trousseau de clés du grenier de la cave
de la buanderie de la gym
désarroi du coffret for all est moins
bien dotées hostile
bah oui elle est heureux qu'apple
personnes hughes from moi je savais que
mon placard
[Applaudissements]
au nom de la loi
ouvrez et ben ils n'ouvrent pas
il faut faire sauter la serrure
s'établissait s'il ne s'agissait que de
faire sauter la serrure on n'aurait pas
besoin
oui on l'enverra chercher le serrurier
tout simplement on a cinquième fois
enfin monsieur le commissaire
je pense qu'il est temps que la police
se décide à agir je m'entends téléphonie
moi-même au préfet mais pendant que vous
y êtes ap dont les pompiers s'est dit
dont vous faites enfin ici au huitième
jour je partirai quand on mord à payer
mon moi et l'arriéré il cette fille doit
rester à notre disposition comme témoin
comme complice oui alors monsieur le
commissaire qu'est ce que vous faites
je réfléchis même pas trop longtemps
parce qu'il ya une journée très chargée
on va compter pour examiner un malade ou
est-il dans le placard on vous dit il
peut montrer le bout de son nez d'une
minute alors avec un peu de chance
hier il est sorti vers cette heure ci
leur côté mais l'odeur du pain grillé et
de la marmelade d'orange attire monsieur
heures de son trou boulimie signe très
caractéristique il lui arrive donc
d'abandonner sa retraite momentanément
docteur hier j'ai pu passer l'aspirateur
elle changeait ses draps mais il
réintègre toujours son placard quoi
qu'on fasse et quoi qu'on dit massa 7e
m'appartient la médecine monsieur le
commissaire j'attends qu'on le lit c'est
ça oui un pas en avant deux pas en
arrière
ils sont que je dresse un constat aura
car je suis venu une première fois
constaté que le disparu avait été
retrouvé vivant dans un placard
aujourd'hui je reviens constater que le
disparu
retrouver ce séquestre dans ce même
plaquages sont deux démarches distinctes
qui donne lieu à deux rapports distincts
est ce que vous allez vous décidez oui
ou non à nous en débarrasser trop avait
la veille a pas trop de plaquages dans
la maison parce que tu veux performer
sont pas tranquilles
deux femmes seules sans défense ne
ferait pas de mal à une mouche
nous on dit cela et puis un matin vous
serez étonné de vous réveiller étrangler
bas il serait peut-être plus tôt en
effet mesdames que vous quittiez cet
appartement jusqu'à nouvel ordre alors
c'est comme si le plus simple n'était
pas de leur barque et lui
et de le remettre entre les mains de qui
donne moi un changement d'ère il serait
peut-être du bien non monsieur le
commissaire aubin vous en avez de bonnes
pour la dernière fois je me sens de
sortie de the black a demandé gentiment
bon allez un peu de dynamiter ce sera
réglé enfin non monsieur commission un
peu d'initiative
bientôt vous n'allez pas m'apprendre mon
métier non non mais quelle histoire qui
vous dit monsieur monsieur je suis très
ennuyé
vous mettez dans dans une situation
extrêmement embarrassant vous entraîniez
qui si nous voulons vous faire sortir de
force nous y arriverons
ce sera extrêmement désagréable pour
tout le monde ou de monsieur je voyais
rationnant à bouaye on jette un père qui
vous parle jamais mon métier n'est pas
drôle tous les jours
cette affaire commence à prendre des
proportions ridicules les journaux s'en
sont emparés ils la racontent à leur
façon une demi-mondaine séquestre son
gendre en première page de la deuxième
édition à laquelle sa fille voit ça de
moi vous avez notre quartier les langues
vont leur prince aujourd'hui j'ai reçu
52 lettres de dénonciation hier c'était
26 demain ce sera ce sera 3 100 en
allant au lait je rencontrais à
conquiert 7 sharon et met à ynet a la
poste je téléphone à mes supérieurs il
me renvoie de l'un à l'autre
personne ne veut prendre de
responsabilités mais ces messieurs de la
pj sont très difficiles vous savez ils
disent que je suis pas la hauteur n'a
voulu ni cd v damez sur les doigts avant
coup de téléphone au préfet a porté ses
fruits et ses amis chez une femme
monsieur jeudi en renforts et des soucis
après elles purent haute c'est la maison
vous êtes là bien tranquille puis tous
les embêtements sont pour moi au super g
allons messieurs c'est y aller fort
hills et vous faire monsieur k
il ouvre toujours pas nos 2 juin le nom
de mieux je fais tu sautes et noir une
marche comme tenu 2 h via bouger
bonjour monsieur le commissaire je vous
l'avais bien dit qu'il fallait prendre
part à sa saisie c'est le vide at-on
prévu ce trio c'est la camisole de force
à qu'elle lui au directeur de l'ap
d'azur ça lui réussit le placard c'est
gentil de venir me revoir monsieur le
commissaire puisse faire quelque chose
pour vous méfiez-vous montgaillard je
peux vous bouclez pour outrage à la
magistrature et ce ne sera pas alors là
il n'est pas injecter voyant les reflex
mais permettez dr laissez le moi il est
à moi aller à nous deux mais qu'est ce
que j'ai fait baboo semer le désordre et
la perturbation dans votre foyer
dans l'immeuble dans le quartier et même
au delà
mais comment cela je fais tout petit je
ne bouge pas ben justement monsieur le
faux faut bouger faut faire comme les
autres et je n'en ai pas envie
c'est pas une raison je croyais pourtant
être un homme libre aa je ne vous le
fais pas dire monsieur un homme libre
n'a pas le droit de ne pas l'être non
pas libre quand vous m'embrouiller
hausse est pourtant simple
la liberté monsieur est obligatoire le
citoyen ne saurait en être privé que par
certains cas prévus par la loi
or en vous enfermant dans votre placard
vous vous privez de votre liberté
illégalement si je vous suis bien
monsieur le commissaire vous même menacé
la prison pour m'apprendre à être un
homme libre a produit exactement
enfermés pour enfermer les c'est moins
lourd dans mon placard à l'eau parce que
vous vous plaisez c'est un gros pas
tible ah oui oui d'une manière générale
oui
autrement dit on est libre de faire ce
qu'il vous plaît pas aux bornes au polo
tout de même vous exagérez là tu pognes
quand même le cinéma les bonnes mères la
pâtisserie les faits tout le reste
tout autre chose un peu différente or
monsieur ce sont des rêves et pour peu
que vous essayez de les concrétiser
autant de délits enfin monsieur le
commissaire je ne fais rien ne meurt pas
dans un monument d'égoïsme vous les avez
entendus
si encore j'avais la regrettable
habitude de faucher les portefeuilles
violer les petites filles ou bien
m'habiller en dame mais là tout ce que
je demande c'est un petit point bien
tranquille et bien l'amour un rail
appelé ce placard ma chambre si cela
peut arranger les choses mais ce n'est
pas votre chope c'est un placard en
finlande il ya la clim
je peux en sortir quand bon me semble
errer dans l'appartement si j'en ai
envie
non monsieur nombre d'ont cela sort par
trop de l'ordinaire eybens admettons que
ce soit une exception
les exceptions mais ce sont les faux
prison ou au cabanon
ah non mais ce serait du jeune tu tout
le monde se mettait à vivre dans les
placards de tenue moi moi moi par
exemple quelle satisfaction rech dans
l'existence je suis co q mon fils est un
cancre et l'avancement que j'attendais
mois dernier mais encore filer sous le
nez vous croyez que si je m'écoutais je
ne me mettrais pas votre place dans le
placard mais non je me retiens comptage
neurasthénie regus et de maladies de
notre époque
moi même je n'y échappe pas le manga
d'une gamine je dois faire mon rapport
docteur g s'examiner le malade à choyer
assez aimable dès que vous avez fini le
fasse à mon bureau afin de me
communiquer votre diagnostic technique
il me tarde de boucler cette affaire
d'une manière ou d'une autre
comptez sur moi monsieur le commissaire
au revoir monsieur le commissaire il
faudrait vous y viendrez t1 à jour il ne
faut jamais mis au placard entre new
york et électoraux ils manquent pas
votre ami vous d'ailleurs y'a pas de
plaque à la chine
pour juste à cacher dit si exigu que
bientôt la petite fille ne pourra plus
se cacher pour jouer le couple voyez
vous cela
votre petite fille déjà triste hérédité
du zona je vais me faire condamner mais
pas votre mari madame mon cachet dit eh
bah dis donc sauvé dit si vous allez à
les raccompagner le commissaire aurait
ici monsieur le commissaire voulait pas
voir un type coup de rouge
non vraiment sans façon bon bah tant pis
devez vous demander de me laisser à
l'instant seul avec monsieur très bien
d'acteurs alors si j'ai bien compris je
ne compte plus sur vous que pour
délibérer mon placard c'est ça nous
allons attendre le résultat à côté mais
tous ces histoires moi j'ai raté les
cours de la bourse aujourd'hui dans
votre poste de radio marche toujours
aussi mal si vous 4 d'heure de la fin
mon pauvre ami alors eu de maintenant
écoute moi je vous en prie pas dans nos
docteurs je serai pas je n'ai pas voulu
de chergé devant le commissaire message
bien que je n'en pense pas moins fou ou
pas j'en ai assez nous sommes mariés
sous le régime de la communauté il me
semble que je me suis montrée assez
compréhensive
la moindre des choses était que tu
partages avec moi ton placard une nous
aurions été un peu à l'étroit ma chérie
mais tu aurais pu me faire une petite
place de temps en temps la nuit mais
c'est toujours la nuit dans le cacao tu
comprends très bien ce que je veux dire
tu me trompes avec ce placard
encore le placard qu'est ce qu'ils ont
tous ceux là d une maladie cueilli c'est
une maladie appelée communément claustro
manie vous en présentait tous les
symptômes droit d'auteur est un des
admins chez vous vous détendez vous
quand vous croyez vraiment que cela ne
va pas mais je me sentirai delà vous
voulez dire du placard le choc
électrique l'urgence et mon traitement
spécial
non je vous assure manon est ainsi fait
il n'y a pas eu de mieux taper
non si nous discutions tranquillement
solide sacrifice je veux vous eh bien
vous avez voulu faire une bonne farce à
votre femme est à votre belle réussite
un bon conseil ne faites pas durer trop
longtemps la plaisanterie ça risquerait
de nous taper sur le système
ça serait pas mal vous êtes sans doute
la seule personne vraiment raisonnable
que j'ai rencontrés au cours d'une
carrière bien remplie
alors là je compte vous les flatter je
ne nie pas un sous genre tout le monde
nous vivons au milieu dit oui et vous
surtout d'acteurs évidemment il pour
prier pour les groupes retenus en garde
le commissaire il est bourré de
complexes votre band l'hystérique il est
le grand monsieur paranoïaque la bonne
nymphomane et morbide je dirais même
dangereux l'ensemble a donc à votre
talent mouchel et mais mentalement dès
qu'il elle n'a pas dépassé l'âge de 10
ans non là de caen je proteste d'affiner
très avancé nous sommes dans minorités
et s'il fallait les soigner tous on ne
s'en sortirait pas moi en tant que
psychiatre je suis en dehors du coup
mais bouquet pour leur échapper et vous
caché dans un placard et vous éveiller
leurs soupçons
forcément c'est épouvantable en tout cas
ce n'est pas facile
vivre raisonnablement au milieu des fous
sans passer spam m
pour moi le problème à la réflexion
docteur peut-être que moi aussi je fais
un peu fou mais avec un petit panneau
soyez palace accepter votre moule imiter
les entraîneurs monde et de temps en
temps pour reprendre souffle je vous
autorise à faire un petit séjour dans le
placard alors la docteure je crois que
pour l'avenir le creux du placard ses
grilles et le plaqueur est un symbole
il ya toute sorte de plaque à tâtonner
voulez-vous me faire plaisir
j'ai mon camargue une cabane au milieu
des mâles
avez vous chasser le canard sauvage si
je veux se mêlent manier la carabine
si l'homme que de chasserait par bonheur
il n'en vient pas jusque là où on se
croirait au bout du monde
pas une à l'aller les moustiques et les
fièvres me protège contre l'ennemi
pas d'électricité pas d'eau pas de
gordes en effet le paradis seul un cas
mais fou me le permettre je vais me
calfeutrer les 7es vous me ferez
l'amitié de venir là bas si quelques
temps ma compagnie tous les deux le sol
que ce sera très content pour les nerfs
alors ces produits importés ils gèrent
ces facteurs que vous avez eu le temps
de constater le tres état dans lequel se
trouve mon job
certes madame sûr remarqué les yeux
exorbités et la démarche à taxi que de
lama lors des changements de régime
troupes russes que risquerait d'aggraver
les choses je garde le malade en
observation ici les laissez lui agir à
sa guise il est très possible que la
réadaptation se fasse des mêmes jeux je
repasserai vers la fin de la semaine
attendez je peux pas vous dire que vous
le laisser sans les bras jusqu'à
nouvelle à 100 c'est beaucoup beaucoup
c'est absolument essentiel maison alors
je raccompagne à ça
voir d'accueil galgo jour bouteille
naturellement aujourd'hui n'y avait pas
de parasites ça pour les mauvaises
nouvelles j'entends toujours très bien
qu'est ce qui ne va pas par un vous avez
la terreur à l'envers hier je lis qui
met actions des salines pour acheter de
l'or est aujourd'hui les salines font un
boum et l'or baisse comme par hasard
alors après il ya des moments où j'ai
envie de tout envoyer aux gardes vous
faites comme moi facile a dit dans mon
placard
je suis avec intérêt l'actualité en
lisant des journaux vieux d'un
demi-siècle voulait prêterait vous y
trouverez les mêmes raisons de vous
faire du mauvais sang et pourtant bah
oui dans un sens vous n'avez pas tort
mais d'un autre côté faut bien
s'intéresser quand on a des intérêts ça
va donc si mal que ça en dehors de pire
en pire je crois je vais faire passer
quelques capitaux en suisse - si cela
vous rassure vous avez des tuyaux
moi j'y connais strictement rien à ça
vous voulez pas le dire j'ai compris je
vais faire revenir tout de suite tout ce
que j'aime bien en suisse mais à quoi
bon et l'afrique du sud
qu'est ce que vous pensez l'afrique du
sud c'est loin n'est ce pas mais les
distances de nos jour que fair où elle
est une île déserte
c'est le seul endroit vivable dans notre
ère atomique
je me demande tout d'un coup si votre
placard n'a pas du bon alors allons par
un faux pas se laisser abattre
mais moi personnellement j'aurais plutôt
choisi mon coffre fort mais vous êtes un
grand sentimental
tout le monde n'a pas votre chose alors
j'ai bien réfléchi dans ma chambre
l'heure des grandes décisions est arrivé
au voilà qui est grave
qu'est ce que tu fais je téléphone à
chochoy faut prendre le taureau par les
cornes
joshua le taureau oui ce soir jusqu'à
albi place et la mise à mort quand j'ai
décidé d'être cruel avec les hommes le
premier qui va me tombait sous la main
il va la sentir passer à propos de
joshua vous ne connaissez pas de
nouvelles ils font fait ça non
et bien parce que vous êtes malade je
vais vous soyez whilst nord votre
placard excusez moi mais ce que vous
disiez dont je voulais simplement vous
dire que chochoy s'était remis avec
josiane paix qu'est ce que vous dites
depuis c'est pas possible ça arrête
adieu veaux vaches mort aux cochons
trouvez-vous il fallait vous d'ici du
but c'est peut-être carabine de chasse
de ce mois
les jeunes et aujourd'hui chez josiane
n'importe unistar changements avaient
l'air très amoureux il y avait un de ces
trafics sous la table et puis elle porte
sur nouveau nés avec beaucoup de grâce
au nouveau né il lui a fait à la fois
mais non son mythe d'une athanasius
appendice nasal ça m'étonnait aussi à
l'est pas assez intelligente pour ça
un chose comme perdu 10 notre elle ne
prend pas sa petite à capable ça j'avoue
c'est un coup dur pour moi toi à toi oui
bien monaco voudrait te réduire en
bouillie t'arracher la pop art
lambourdes enfoncé 10,5 mètres sous les
ongles ou mâcher coup j'ai une baisse
donc pas je ne rigole pas tu as tout cas
chez lui à cause de toi j'ai raté au
chômage j'ai laissé passer un rôle de
second plan mais enfin de caractère dans
une propos de réductions vont franco
égyptienne oh non je n'ai plus le goût à
rien mais j'ai put m'ont dit que j'étais
bête à manger du foie alors puisque me
la police ils émettent ça ne veulent de
vous puisque vous a tiré sur ma maison
la ruine le désespoir
puisque vous êtes décidé à avoir ma peau
avait croupi dans votre placard je vous
le laisse avec la maison l'appartement
par dessus le marché toutes les factures
à payer
j'accepte je garderai placard et je sue
lourd elle reste non mais là je pars
avec toi à chacun pour soi ma petite
fille a servi de l'hôtel revient très
cher
je ne suis pas du tout disposés web et
enfin vous irez vous à sidi bou said
j'ai le pacha que je n'ai pas vu depuis
des années et qui me réclame à cor et à
cri dans un rêve non au désert j'ai trop
lutter je bouge applique désormais
laissant pousser mes cheveux leur
couleur naturelle plus de maquillage
visage nu dépouillé d'artifice plus de
massage et de régime je jette ma gueule
je vous laisse vous voulez
il en aura une autre surprise le pacha
rédemption des grandes sécheresses
c'est comme si maintenant prenez le
voile les voiles oui à dieu tous je plie
bagage désormais séparé du monde par un
moucharabieh loi d'exception humaine je
goûterai le silence et la solitude
pourquoi partir vous enfermez si loin
belle-maman rien au placard jusqu'au
fond du couloir la deuxième avec des
appareils qui valent absolument entrer
encore dit c'est pour personne mais quel
appareil ils sont mal élevés
tpr étendard des journalistes alors ça
c'est vraiment une race à part lui
manque un fixe à renoncer surtout pas
mon non surtout pas mais qu'est ce qui
peut bien vouloir
moi j'aurais dit oui bonjour bon on vous
dit bonjour le journal bonjour bon vous
désirez une interview prendre quelques
photos puis la maîtresse de maison
je voulais dire tout de suite que toute
allusion à ma vie privée risque de vous
coûter cher à bonne entendeur salut
d'ailleurs d'ailleurs je refuse de
répondre à vos questions
c'est pas vous qui vous êtes enfermé bon
alors vous ne nous intéressait pas
powell blake un papa tête de l'art ils
crèvent les yeux a juste je m'excuse on
est pressé ben oui les vies de merde
alors permettez monsieur abbas et vous
fallait le dire leur fermait pas
attention ne bougeait pas merci c'est à
moi que vous en voulez monsieur ben oui
quand vous consacre un grand reportage
en double page j'espère que nous sommes
bien des premiers il doit y avoir erreur
enfin monsieur n'étant pas au courant de
quoi ça alors vous vivez vous
l'ajustement vous êtes l'homme du jour
encore une photo
si vous avez l'intention de la publier
et à la une ne rend pas très bien
d'habitude et vous voulez raconter mon
histoire sa faute ou nous dire comment
cela at-il commencé
vous prenez un peu au dépourvu moi qui
ai toute ma vie je suis passé
complètement inaperçu
moi qui n'ai jamais intéressé mais plus
proche j'ai peine à croire que tout d'un
coup des milliers de lecteurs puissent
être passionné par ma petite personne
non non messieurs non ça n'a aucun sens
je ne suis pas celui que vous cherchez
le coûteux que vous le vouliez ou non il
nous faut notre peau retard et on l'aura
vas-y follow me trahis pour ça que je ne
vois vraiment pas l'intérêt que cela
peut représenter de 50 ans dimanche à
grantham
laissez vous faire monsieur c'est la
rançon de la gloire je ne suis même pas
rasé faites moi un petit rictus vous
souriez tout le temps ces pans de la
lèvre l'oeil hagard soyez inquiétant bon
ben je veux bien faire un petit effort
pour vous être agréable mais nous mais
d'utiliser pas après ça vous est lancé à
saint germain des prés on parle déjà que
de vous vous avez des adeptes enragé
well et l'interdistrict les plaques
artistes et les antis placard dist vous
êtes l'apôtre d'une philosophie nouvelle
le placard tic ce moment possible
on signale déjà pas mal de disparition
dans le quartier romano vous avez la
musau cheveux plats et bien elle s'est
enfermée pendant 12 heures dans la
cabine téléphonique de la station au dr
bah moi j'vous l'dit la partie est
gagnée il est question d'une
interpellation à la chambre la chambre
ça risque de faire du pétard la droite
vous attaquent violemment au nom de la
dignité humaine ceux de gauche au
contraire défendant vous les droits de
l'homme
j'ai entendu parler de ce n'est tout à
l'heure à la radio que je n'ai pas fait
le rapprochement
j'en suis baba bien garni et tout ça
parce que je me suis enfermé dans un
placard
qu'est ce que c'est que j'avais chaud en
plein mois de décembre est bien attrapé
une bronchite au mois d'août les choses
ça ferait pas un mauvais clichés non
plus le ch de quoi venir toi cache pas
de pellicule compris je travaille aussi
dans la photo d'art vos téléphones tous
les matins avant 9 heures pour vous
jusqu'à 9h15 le président bongo a qui
croyez vous parlez là allez vous fichent
la paix à ma femme quoi votre paume et
vous vous enfermez dans un placard alors
là je suis plus du tout d'accord bekolo
une dernière pause en vitesse prête
quand vous voudrez et messieurs
normalement ça
la femme de la moussaka samedi rien que
s'ils croient les imériens qu attendait
le permettez mon propre ego c'est le
meilleur 10dans il est empreint de la
plaque quand on lit gauche
alloway les chouchous il ya un sacré
show chaud mois sur une erreur madame je
connais pas du tout ce monsieur ou
permettait j'espère signer tout de même
pas pour me demander la main de ma femme
oui oui lui mal mais je vous écoute
pourquoi pas des films tu peux me donner
le nom de ton après cervioni rien à voir
ici c'est que douze 12 pourquoi merci
n'ya rien maman bitchy cdu en 12
s'occupe de nos intérêts j'espère que
nous mettrons d'accord sessad une
affaire qui peut être intéressant audi
vide
ce soin de se servir de mon nom et de ma
personnalité pour la publicité de son
nouvel insecticide réchou chouih net
mais j'en suis un des principaux
actionnaires pas il est fort le show
choir la fifille l'homme dakar n'est pas
manger au mitage à l'acheminent est faux
tout prix même si ces records vous savez
vous laissez pas faire mais si il ya
bien avant que je vous ai mis en rapport
avec la terreur des cafards puis
attention attention on y mettra le point
oui j'espère bien ce sera très cher
n'oubliez pas que je suis un vieil ami
de la famille vous savez j'ai presque
fait sauter votre femme son genou
le talent est fragile avant d'amis
l'amitié jose les affaires ont senti
trop mais pas trop fatigué conti à vrai
que c'est une de vos premières sorties
bon il se fait tard il faut encore que
je passe au journal que je fasse mon
papier au revoir tout le monde merci
monsieur l'homme a sans indiscrétion
qu'est ce que vous faites continuez dans
le placard au revoir monsieur et merci
c'est byzance vous êtes ouvert vous
savez à votre entière disposition
j'étais bien mais moi monsieur
nous évitons que ça dure
[Applaudissements]
cette journée aura été fertile en
surprises à j'en ai toujours dit et moi
la chair de poule alors bella vous
partez toujours pour sidi bou saïd
je me tâte
vous savez ce sera bientôt notre
anniversaire un forum nous allions en
séjour chez cartier séjour tout de suite
voilà vous savez c'est vraiment pas je
n'ai jamais de la vie
peinture est un ba1 le temps de passer
mis ko grand fou vous savez bella c'est
surtout l'intention qui compte on a
intérêt à tout le monde pas d'arranger
les choses avaient avec ton mari là
après tout c'est pas un mauvais garçon
si vous voulez mais est bas
alors voilà célèbre ses lèvres
c'est un photos qu'on va voir dans les
journaux c'est ton nom qu'on va
connaître peut-être même que des gens
viendront te demander des autographes
avoue que c'est cocasse mais oui quand
cassez vous je détestais la publicité
tels que l'on fait autour des eaux
mais maintenant que c'est moi qui suis
sur la sellette et bien et nous savons
ou moins désagréable et je dirais même
que ça me plaît le monde est absurde
delphine il faut se faire une raison non
j'aimerais direct mais regarde moi mais
c'est ce que je me révolte mois alors ça
c'est un comble pourquoi veux-tu enfermé
dans un placard alors parce que je
prenais les choses trop au sérieux
je m'étonne fait tort mais c'était mieux
je te les soit fort et tu veux vraiment
servir de publicité pour la chouchou il
est bon de voir mon mari collées sur les
murs et dans les réclames des journaux
j'ai l'impression que ça va nous faire
un drôle d'effet
voilà donc la première fois que je me
rencontrerait au coin d'une rue au coin
d'une rue ou dans le métro dans le métro
mais vu qu il n'y a pas de danger que
cela puisque tu seras toujours dans ton
placard mais tout de même
tu verras ont commencé à sortir un peu
et pourquoi ça et parce que tu perdrais
ta situation
sorti du placard tu le vaux rien allez
allez faut montrer au monde et à la
conscience professionnelle puisque nous
sommes seuls personnes verront bas au
moins une fois que nous pouvons bavarder
un peu tous les deux seuls sinon j'ai
des scrupules à tunis 13 entre dit un
instant avec moi non ce serait déplacé
tu l'as dis toi même mais je vais
laisser la porte ouverte que je puisse
te vois tu triches faut pas faire les
choses à moitié
bien qu est ce que tu attends je passais
delphine je ne peux pas
je ne peux plus chéri c'est décidé je
plaque le pas car je te préfère que je
laisse tout tomber tant pis pour la
gloire
tu sais je croyais fuir un tas de choses
et en fait je ne fis y'a que moi mais tu
es sûr que tu ne reviendra jamais ton
placard
je suis mon propre au placard je suis
blindé
on va se pourvoir tu n'es pas si bien
que ça elle jette en l'air
jusqu'où jusqu'à station la new trabi au
coupé ma vie on va c'est vraiment devant
le succès le moment non je t'assure mon
petit chou j'ai besoin de savoir où il
m'a écouté les yeux fermés découvre
sarkozyste
[Applaudissements]
la pièce que nous avons eu le plaisir de
représenter ce soir devant vous et de
barillet et grédy
[Applaudissements]
des corps de roger hart
des bascules de donneurs calmes
[Applaudissements]
mise en scène de jacques hardoin
christian aubert fusil
roland oberlin
soirée
[Applaudissements]
hélène duc
un vélo garé dit
[Applaudissements]
taguieff d'harare
j'ai un carquois
gagné
[Applaudissements]
à
et mony dalmès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]